les cherry en ce moment vous savez que
il ya maths il ya magda renom qui est
chez moi c'est mon cousin
il ya également matt damon savait qu'à
matt damon oui oui oui matt damon à
siwel affleck
ouais ils sont à sarlat en dordogne sur
le tournage du film the last duel y est
ça veut dire le dernier duel
c'est un rire et scott brown celui qui
fait les blues ont d'ailleurs lé chili
ont du coup je vous dis je me suis
renseigné pareil que matt damon
ouais il a parfois dîné dans les
restaurants de la ville d'accord je me
suis dit est ce qu'on ferait pas une
mini d'arca pour faire gagner un beau
cadeau publique tap si j'arrive à rester
unie lutte avec un restaurant de sarlat
en me faisant passer pour l'agent
américain tomates damaseb mal pas mal je
fais gagner un cadeau à tous les fans de
foot
alors on va appeler restaurant tout de
suite on y va c'est préfère l'accent de
[Musique]
recruter lire et où vous la couleuvrine
aucun de l'épidémie ajouté leurs efforts
pour trouver toute l'année merci de
patienter quelques instants nous allons
donner suite à votre appel
voici la couleuvrine alors qu'ils
étaient bons gestes et les mots sans que
leur coeur oui bonjour c'est faux nez
oui oui bonjour stéphane et c'est john
stevens
je vous je vous appelle pour matt damon
il était déjà venu manger des burgers
il ya quelques jours oui voudraient
revenir manger un hamburger
oui oui c'est possible oui parce que le
dernière fois vous nous avez aimé dans
une petite salle il faudrait il aimerait
changer de salle parce qu'il a eu froid
d'accord alors est ce que c'est possible
c'est bien stéphanie oui il va venir
tout leur il y avait deux amies et peut
avec onze personnes de l'équipe qui
veulent manger appel ils viennent avec
aux personnes de l'équipe
ils ont faim ils ont faim kéfa après le
tournage
d'accord très bien c'est possible oui
alors je dis à matino ap
ça là bas
c'est fanny stéphanie salut doit mettre
la table à pau et quel talent
est ce que vous voulez
est ce qu'on voulait que j'en appelle à
prévenir alors c'est parti on appelle le
à tiennent donc la tienne on peut
comparer la seule à faire vraiment plage
fans anglais on pense pas qu'on en est
sûr mais tel chrono humides en anglais
adresse concentré à l'eau votre
correspondant vous disent en attendre
on nous signifie cette mascarade
alors est-ce qu'elle inspire
je peux tu as une prise du boss jon
super diamono for one touch wood à
touring ou madame mode homme apparemment
ils ont accroché ses toiles
d'où l'appel du liban
j'ai pu voir quelques films avec matt
damon en vo ouais ça ne m'est pas même
si sur deux voies soit non cm3 c'est
quelque chose en vous inquiéter jean
claude hamel de nous surprendre par
l'épinglé sérieuse de zubrus et partie
du bassin l'influente jouzou base quoi
la décennie t2c des zouzous s'il avoue 7
quel personnage la probable vous pouvez
laisser un message nous retrouver sur
nos contacts avec vous ils ont pas ils
n'ont pas vérifié avant allez on appelle
la calabre tient une pizzéria cadors là
je vais faire mais c'est matt damon
s'est pas attention attention matt damon
je rappelle que matt damon et à sarlat
en ce moment et on fera gagner un cadeau
bien sûr c'est que si on reste avec eux
si on si sympathique on va voir on n'a
pas un smartphone à l'o2 le calabre la
calabre oui oui ya ce bonjour monsieur
je suis assistant du madame haman des
systèmes de madame louis matte is il est
dans le région ont sûrement d'accord oui
oui il aime beaucoup le blizzard a
d'accord pour monsieur la flamande
oui oui on aime beaucoup le blizzard oui
et le des quotas ce possible de manger
une pizza
il n'y a pas de problème ils veulent
devenir ce soir le mot juif izard
d'accord oui je pense qu'il n'ya pas
non
allô allô oui allô la calabre où la
calabre la calabre je suis désolé mais
c'est pas madame c'est cyril hanouna
[Applaudissements]
la callas monsieur je voudrais vous
offrir un smartphone parce que vous avez
été très sympathique d'accord avec un
matt damon qui sur sûr ça va exactement
aussi une pizza d'accord vous l'avez
rencontré matt ou pas pas du tout on est
très sympa alors oui je sais qui prend
une calzone - jambon plus ton temps et
je n'ai pas de temps et va écouter on
voit ici au mans n'a en revanche à vous
je vous fais des bisous comment vous
appelez c'est quoi votre prénom c'est
quoi d'un club jean claude jacob agent
que je te fais des normes bisous
d'accord mais si je passe à sarlat je
viendrai la calabre la pizzeria c'est
quoi votre spécialité de la calabre ya
quoi dedans dans la calabre où
jean-claude avec de chorizo courant
confie à wes cates l'huile d'olive
basilic comité tout le reste tu fais
tout ce qu'ils ont offerts au québec tu
pas un gros bisou gens tu es comme un
smartphone sa mémoire est encore très
sympa
[Applaudissements]
c est ce qu ont pressé les clients et
vous voulez en faire un dernier un
dernier allait on l'appelle l'entrepôt
tu notre avis de mode qui mangent les
entrecôtes merci de dessin je vais faire
je vais refaire le le sustt en
récidivant moi je veux dire que je suis
pas ce matin grade
je vais faire un commissaire après quand
matt damon olala commissaire domicile
[Rires]
mais la mi complice il aurait d'autres
potes et peuvent pas répondre à la
crêperie le héros de la all dessins
animés des ballons bêtes en battant je
vais faire je vais faire un jeu faire un
inspecteur qui avec l'assistant de ola
devient scénario à la pipe je suis reach
et des papilles répit avant les numéros
de connard ils ont viré taisons toujours
vérifier vous verrez demain vous verrez
ferrer votre fiche de paye
allez un dernier mois dernier on peut on
peut faire ses habitants qu'est ce que
tu connais quand c'est les restos et son
envie sa bosse pas beaucoup à sarlat tu
portes au site shop
c'est le coup de feu comme on lit en bus
ligne est fermée restaurant vous avez
mémoire doit aller bien le dernier
je te jure si l'aca avait comparé je
vous le dis je je stoppe toute la région
si je fais un commissaire la saison nous
ont donné il ya matt damon qui à sarlat
je vais faire un commissaire qui appelle
sa main et capel un resto pour réserver
parce que là l'assistant qui venait
t'amuser rien n'est pas bien et qui est
tout du trou moi j'aurais taylor a
répondu moi bienvenue
[Applaudissements]
il en reste deux il en reste deux
mais dans le personnage
chapin comédien henri viii qui ferait
pour sa commissaire a pas envie de
rigoler avait envie de déconner les
chéris il va me rester une chanson de
congé en janvier vous maniez vous de
pire en pire et sans regret si vous êtes
vraiment déchaîné un olivier à bien
non mais sort ils n'ont pas réussi à
avoir une personne mais qu'est ce que
c'est que cette bande normal
et
[Applaudissements]
les personnes
personne personne et personne ne pouvait
nous ré expliquer la raison pour
laquelle seclin lunaire est avec matt
damon ou sous l'onglet ces [ __ ] à
damon hill et avec la seconde la mode
masculine difficulté l'assistant de matt
damon veut que matt damon manche mais
matt damon n'arrive pas à manger au sein
de sarlat donc ils appellent le
restaurant pour réserver la table pour
l'assistant a fallu passer les voir
c'est un scénario à double tiroirs où
aller ils ont dû se passer le mois sa
mort ils écoutent oui bonjour la petite
marie oui oui mon jour c'est le
commissaire feuillus de la drpj de
sarlat gens nous appellent concernant
l'individu susnommé matt damon qui est
sur la région sar la sienne oui que tu
appelles les grands oui je vous appelle
concernant éventuellement une mise en
demeure puisque la personne aurait volé
les souks et e
hier en milieu bouliste yk1 je suis bien
là petit bourricot rihanna et bien sûr
monsieur aux appels concernant
l'individu susnommé matt damon
l'acteur américain est exactement qui
était avec eux bana flic witter je vous
appelle concernant ces de malotrus qui
aurait commis ces quelques échauffourées
sur la raison sar la scène concernant un
vol de chouquettes
éventuellement puisque j'ai eu au
téléphone la drpp de cire la de sa
commune
oui le sexe et point commissarait mais
parait-il que vous auriez vu des
susnommés un 10 minutes qui se serait
même passé devant chez vous avec 12 ou
qu est la vie lors par là qu il avait vu
sa maladie il avait l'air un petit peu
spéciaux g spéciaux du tableau bon il
avait l'air heureuse et détendue où tu
es drôle et quoi bon alors actuellement
je suis je suis en enquête poussée au
niveau de ces deux individus puisqu'on
les recherches actuellement dans la
région
apparemment ils auraient mal et les
souks est de type b des chouquettes de
type b c'est à dire à mes yeux des
petits morceaux de sucre sur la
chouquette et commence à vous aider mais
dieu vous voulez réserver table alors
éventuellement oui pour essayer
éventuellement puisqu'il paraît que ces
deux individus sont vraiment les chez
vous dans les prochains jours ah bon
j'aimerais passer en filature le secret
vous avez une table secrète
non je veux une table secrète et le
commissaire fueling de la drpj seul l
c'est à dire payer deux salles à
monsieur tulasne nantes étoiles
[Applaudissements]
la petite grille ces séries la nuit en
fête
cécile un noble et ton direct je vous
offre un smartphone et grâce à vous tous
le public à gagner un cadeau
c'est un peu lourd
wattez rêver josé projet gros gibier
projet ben je vous fais un gros bisou
angers ok bah mon style en moi et en
brasserie valérie benaïm a préféré
[Applaudissements]
je dois vous offrir dans mon récent et
roger est ce que je peux vous offrir un
week-end à paris la révision de tous les
monuments même pas l'aider mais nîmes
est ce que je peux vous voyez il ya ces
mots je vous embrasse rezé j'ai beaucoup
moins ruggie vous êtes célibataire et
compliqué
[Applaudissements]
alors je vous invite à parier nous voir
dans touche pas à mon pote visite bien
sûr de tout outil en tutti quanti
et puis on vous fera des beaux cadeaux
d'accord rôle et on récupère et rosiers
je vous adore alors et je le dis parce
que je vois beaucoup j'en ai rien à
[ __ ]
c'est la petite borie vous faites quoi
c'est quoi la spécialité de la petite
marie curie vous faites un petit peu
d'heures à lufa de catégorie b avec des
petits sucre dessus mais ce week-end
roger vous êtes formidables ont fait
d'énormes bisous
je